tras ocho años al mando el momento de la
izquierda podría llegar a su fin los
partidos de derecha y extrema derecha
llevan la delantera por un estrecho
margen tras las elecciones legislativas
sin embargo los socialdemócratas de la
primera ministra magdalena a anderson
aún no conceden la derrota pues queda un
5% de los distritos electorales por
contar los partidos de derecha
controlarían 175 de los 349 escaños en
el parlamento apenas uno más que el
bloque de izquierda pero para algunos la
tendencia es clara
esto es creo que es una declaración de
que los suecos quieren un cambio
definitivamente sólo es impactante
porque creo que para muchos suecos es
difícil entender que estaríamos dando un
giro tan obvio hacia la derecha hacia la
extrema derecha
el sentimiento antiinmigrante en el país
y los constantes episodios de violencia
en los suburbios entre bandas criminales
han debilitado la popularidad del
partido gobernante
suecia cuenta con una sociedad
acostumbrada a tener varias protecciones
sociales desde que nacen hasta que
mueren el resto y después todos los
suecos son básicamente socialdemócratas
donde queremos un estado fuerte queremos
un bienestar fuerte queremos un buen
sistema escolar financiado con fondos
públicos entonces los votantes
demócratas suecos no son de derecha en
ese sentido pero los suecos tienen miedo
del desarrollo negativo del mundo y de
suecia
según la ley sueca el partido que
obtiene la mayor cantidad de escaños
forma el próximo gobierno el más
opcionado para convertirse en el próximo
primer ministro es el moderado wulff
christer son pero de confirmarse los
resultados el bloque de extrema derecha
que cuenta con supremacistas blancos
entre sus fundadores quedaría con gran
poder en la toma de decisiones la
inflación más alta en tres décadas y la
crisis energética que azota a varios
países de europa también se tomaron la
agenda
lo que posiblemente no cambiará a pesar
de que cambie el gobierno es la adhesión
del país a la otan con la invasión rusa
aún como telón de fondo